what's up instagram amanda bynes here
my court date is coming up in two weeks
amanda bynes returns to instagram after
taking the first step in ending her
conservatorship after nearly nine years
and the first thing she's doing thanking
her fans i want to thank you all so much
for your love and support
peace out the 35 year old actress sports
a new look black locks that fade into
gray black glasses and a gold septum
piercing amanda's rare video message
comes less than two weeks after she
filed a petition to terminate the
conservatorship of her person and estate
in california's ventura county superior
court her attorney confirmed the news to
e.t and told people amanda wishes to
terminate her conservatorship she
believes her condition is improved and
protection of the court is no longer
necessary the actress's next hearing is
scheduled for march 22nd now if amanda's
petition is granted what's the timeline
for termination tamar armanak the lawyer
who represents amanda's parents told et
about the general process back in 2019.
there would be a hearing a whole process
it could take as much as a week to two
weeks it's almost like a mini trial
where each side would be able to bring
in subpoena their witnesses bring in
their documents and show and prove their
case amanda's conservatorship has been
handled by her mother lynn bynes since
august 2013. lynn oversees her
daughter's personal and medical
decisions as well as financial affairs
the conservatorship was first put into
place when amanda was 27 after she had
several run-ins with police and was
placed under an involuntary psychiatric
hold amanda later admitted that at the
time she'd been under the influence like
when she wrote that infamous tweet about
drake when you told drake to murder your
vagina
i actually wasn't being insincere i was
like
saying
murder my vagina
you're serious i was serious but i was
also on drugs
so that was my way of saying like
let's do it man
but i was like on drugs and trying to be
hilarious in recent years the hairspray
star has kept a low profile but also
shared little life updates with fans
like this one in 2020. i wanted to check
in let you know that i'm out to dinner
right now with my friend kathy who's a
student advisor at bitum my college i'm
really looking forward to starting my
clothing line that same year amanda
announced she was engaged and expecting
a child with paul michael a man she met
in a sober living facility but not too
long after the former nickelodeon star's
lawyer told et that she was not pregnant
but that she was in a safe location and
doing very well and when amanda turned
35 last april etie learned she was
leading a quiet life living near the
beach still attending fashion school and
working toward earning a bachelor's
degree it's a sentiment she reflected in
this interview back in 2017. i've been
going to school lately fashion school
fitum
and i love it i've learned how to sew i
make patterns
and i want to start a clothing line in
the future so fitm has been helping me
with that other than that i hike i go
spinning take spinning classes
and i feed the homeless and that's been
really interesting and fun
[Music]
you